hallo herzlich willkommen in meiner
torten will heute gibt es endlich wieder
ein video von mir und ich habe jetzt
zwei wochen kein video mehr hochgeladen
und zwar wissen wir einige von euch dass
ich prüfungen hatte
die habe ich jetzt alle rum jetzt will
ich fertige lehrerin und hat keine
prüfungen mehr
deswegen kommen jetzt auch meine oster
videos sind zwar ein bisschen knapper
ostern aber natürlich noch pünktlich zum
osterfest so dass ihr alles noch nach
backen kennt ich werde jetzt heute mit
diesen cupcakes beginnen und habe hier
zuckersüße cupcake förmchen die treibt
euch mal und zwar geht die in so einer
schönen geschenke verpackung jeweils
zwei designs pro farbe und da habe ich
fünf verschiedene farben und wird heute
aber nicht die pinkfarbenen benutzen
sondern lila und gelb und hier könnt ihr
sehen einmal gibt das design mit punkten
und einmal mit streifen und in einem
päckchen sind jeweils sechs stück
gepunktete und sechs stück gestreift
drin und ich finde die wirklich
zuckersüß markt die muffins direkt darin
dass dem papier förmchen und da kann man
ganz toll cupcakes dekorieren
ich habe jetzt heute gleich zwei rezepte
varianten für euch und zwar einmal
zucchini cupcakes und einmal möhren
cupcakes und welt sagt oh gott zucchini
oder möhren mag ich gar nicht ihr müsst
es auf jeden fall trotzdem versuchen
man schmeckt das gemüse nämlich nicht
raus und dieses gemüse gibt den cupcakes
einfach so richtig die feuchtigkeit und
die schmecken richtig schön saftig auch
nach 234 tagen
und die müsste auf jeden fall probieren
ich habe jetzt ein grundrezept gemacht
und zeigt euch jetzt erst einmal die
zutaten für die karotten also für diesen
karotten teig und danach zeige ich euch
auch die zutaten für den zug init eick
bei den karotten habe ich nämlich
bisschen den geschmack variiert und bei
dem zug linie auch und ich zeige euch
immer jeweils die zutaten für zwölf
cupcakes also genau für so ein päckchen
können auch ganz normale muffin papier
förmchen nehmen
aber diese natürlich viel hübscher und
ich zeige ich es einfach mal die zutaten
und dann geht's weiter
für den teig braucht ihr zwei eier 100
gramm zucker 90 gramm öl da habe ich
jetzt sonnenblumenöl weiß
geschmacksneutral ist ihr braucht einen
löffel backpulver 125 gramm mehl und 80
gramm gemahlene nüsse da könnt ihr
haselnüsse nehmen oder ihn in walnüssen
ihr könnt aber auch mandel nehmen und
ihr braucht 150 gramm karotten und wer
gerne etwas aroma möchte kann jetzt die
schale einer unbehandelten orange mit
dazu geben oder etwas zimt da würde ich
einen halben teelöffel nehmen
und weil ich jetzt heute etwas frischer
mag nehme ich hier die orange und für
die variante mit zucchini nehme ich 150
gramm zucchini den natürlich mit schale
einen halben teelöffel zimt und ich
nehme hier nur 100 gramm mehl und dafür
noch 25 gramm gerasterte zarte
schokolade und jetzt zeige ich euch
einfach wie man den teig herstellt ich
zeig dir jetzt einmal beim karotten tag
und sage ich natürlich dann auch noch
wie ich der zucchini teig herstellen
in der herstellung bleiben sie aber
gleich eben nur einmal dass ich dann die
das gemüse austausche und deswegen gehen
wir jetzt zur küchenmaschine aber
natürlich könnt ihr das ganze auch ohne
küchenmaschine mit einem schneebesen
oder mit einem handrührgerät verrühren
zuerst gibt die jetzt die eier in eurem
mix top-klasse die eier kurz verrühren
auf höchster stufe und gebt dann nach
und nach den zucker mit azubis er sich
komplett aufgelöst hat und bis das ganze
eine richtig schöne cremige masse ist
so cremig sollte die masse dann aussehen
und dann könnt ihr euer mehr 17
gemeinsam mit dem backpulver
dann kommen auch die haselnüsse
betreiben und das öl die möhren werde
ich jetzt direkt mit dieser gemüse
trommel hier rein raspeln und hier gebe
ich jetzt auch direkt noch die
orangenschale mit rein und jetzt wird
alles einfach nur noch schön
untergehoben beim zucchini teil bleibt
die zubereitung genau gleich und zwar
wird da anstelle der karotten einfach
der zucchini gerastet und einfach auch
mitunter gehoben und dann werden die
förmchen damit ausgefüllt und in die
gelben schildchen fühle ich jetzt meine
zucchini teig ein und die individuen
schälchen fühle ich meinen karotten tag
ein
könnt ihr sehen dass sich die förmchen
etwa zu drei viertel mit dem teig
gefühlt habe und jetzt kommen sie bei
etwa 175 grad ober und unterhitze für ca
20 bis 25 minuten in den ofen auf jeden
fall solltet ihr dann die stäbchen probe
machen so sehen die cupcakes jetzt
fertig gebacken aus
ich sehe diesen richtig schön
aufgegangen und so werde ich jetzt
einmal komplett abkühlen lassen und
werden derzeit schon mal die deko
vorbereiten
für die dekoration benutze ich 150 gramm
tat bitter kuvertüre hier habe ich ein
paar kleine salzstangen und hier habe
ich ein paar deko eier
das sind welche von milka diese milka
mini ex aber ihr könnt diese eier falls
er den nicht bekommt oder die nicht
schön findet natürlich auch zum beispiel
auswandern oder marzipan selbst machen
ich habe mir überlegt dass ich daraus
diese süßen ist hier mache mit den
kleinen eier
hierfür wird die schokolade jetzt zuerst
geschmolzen ich werde sie natürlich
temperieren damit sie eben die richtige
temperatur hat nämlich 32 grad
und wenn sie dafür jetzt einmal klein
hacken
dann wird die kuvertüre im wasserbad
geschmolzen das heißt ihr stellt einfach
die schokolade in ein warmes wasserbad
bis sie komplett geschmolzen ist und
dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder wenn
die schokolade dann geschmolzen ist gibt
es sie in ein kleines gefäß nicht alles
einfach nur ein bisschen und hier gebe
ich jetzt ein paar die werden jetzt
komplett mit der schokolade bitte und
dann arbeitet ihr am besten mit zwei
gabeln und baut euch jetzt ein kleines
nest und zwar setzt ihr dafür diese
salzstangen einfach so hin und last in
der mitte ein kleines loch frei damit da
nämlich dann die eier reinpassen
und es muss gar nicht symmetrisch sein
einfach irgendwie und so groß wie ihr
das eben möchte
bevor ihr hier jetzt die eier
draufsetzen können müssen die nester
erstmal fest werden deswegen gibt es sie
kurz in den kühlschrank bis einfach
dieser glanz weg ist daran erkennt ihr
dass ihr dann getrocknet sind und dann
setzen wir die eier drauf für die
selbstgemachten eier habe ich etwas
blüten passte genommen ihr könnt auch
von hand nehmen und habe meine
pastellfarben genommen die pastell
passend farben weil die einfach so schön
hell sind und hab dann die fondant und
blüten passten stücke zu kleinen eiern
geformt und ich hab das nicht ganz
verknetet damit sie einfach so ein
bisschen musterung hatten und so
entstanden dann schöne eier und dann
könnt ihr die eier auf die nestchen
setzen
und wenn ihr merkt dass ihr euch runter
rutschen oder runter fallen dann könnte
einfach etwas schokolade nehmen die
etwas damit benetzen und die dann
draufkleben solange die nester jetzt
wieder abkühlen und fest werden werde
ich die krähen vorbereiten die cupcakes
fertig machen und dann kommen die deko
schon drauf ich werde jetzt eine
frischkäse buttercreme machen ihr könnt
aber auch eine mascarpone creme nehmen
oder einfach den frischkäse auch durch
schmandt et cetera austauschen aber bei
frischkäse und butter hat man einfach
den vorteil dass die creme richtig schön
standfest ist und nichts mehr läuft denn
viele haben wir das problem dass die
creme verläuft bei cupcakes und wenn ihr
diese frischkäse und butter variante
nimmt ist sie schön fest aber auch schön
frisch und dafür braucht er jetzt immer
von allen drei zutaten also butter
zucker butter und frischkäse die
gleichen teile falls ihr jetzt zwölf
cupcakes macht reichen einfach 100 gramm
von allem also 100 gramm puderzucker 100
gramm butter und 100 gramm frischkäse
wenn er die doppelte menge macht könnt
ihr 200 gramm von allem nehmen
ich hatte ursprünglich 300 gemacht aber
hatte daneben noch ein drittel der creme
übrig deswegen würde ich euch raten nur
100 gramm von allem zu nehmen
zuerst gebt ihr jetzt die butter in
früher topf oder in den mixed ob und die
butter unter frischkäse die sollten
beide zimmertemperatur haben so erst
will jetzt die butter ganz lange weiß
cremig gerührt
und jetzt gebe ich während dem rühren
nach und nach den puderzucker mit dazu
und lass es schön weiter rühren
wenn das dann richtig schön luftig
geschlagen ist kommt jetzt noch der
frischkäse mit dazu für die tempi
kopiert und schmeckt lecker riecht
mädchen lecker schmeckt ja und das wird
jetzt einmal ganz kurz eingerührt und
fertig ist unsere leckere krems und wer
will kann hier zum beispiel noch
zitronensaft dazugeben
oder ein paar aromen oder etwas vanille
zucker so dass es einfach ein anderes
aroma annimmt und schmeckt gut nicht gut
ok schotte jetzt sehe ich mit beutel mit
einer lok hülle ihr könnt mich auch eine
rosette stühlen - zeigt euch beide und
stift es immer mal stritten stände und
da gebe ich jetzt einen teil der creme
rein
hier könnt ihr übrigens ein paar sehen
die jetzt noch modelle tab auswandern
und die hier sind von samira und jetzt
nehme ich mir einfach meine kappe nehme
jetzt einfach mal die mit zucchini
bespritzt ich dir einfach mit dieser
creme
und dann könnt ihr diese bunten es
darauf setzen und zeigt dann fertig wenn
euch das mit dem nest so aufwendig ist
neben dir einfach ein paar schoko späne
und gebt sie darüber über diese creme
und könnt euch praktisch aus schoko
späne neuer nest fahren und könnt ihr
dann ein paar eier drauf geben
das wäre so die einfachere und
schnellere variante um die schoko später
herzustellen die durch einfach im block
schokolade und zieht mit dem messer
flach drüber und dann seht ihr dass sie
hier die schoko spiele ab kratzt und so
sehen nun die fertigen cupcakes aus und
hier einer durfte auch ein schmetterling
sein
da habe ich einfach zwei rätsel genommen
hier in smarties und diese gummi schnüre
und hier habe ich etwas fondant geformt
und einfach in die mitte gegeben und die
cupcakes sind wirklich super lecker ich
würde euch nur raten etwas weniger creme
darauf zu geben
aber wenn ihr bei der frischkäse creme
eben nur diese 100 gramm pro tag nimmt
dann spritzte einfach etwas weniger
drauf denn ich finde so ein bisschen zu
mächtig also aber ich war auch die
einzige die das so findet also mein mann
und alle anderen sagen das ist super so
vom verhältnis wenn ihr also die kleben
so haben wollt wie ich nehmt ihr 150
gramm zutaten und ansonsten wenn es
etwas weniger haben wollt nur 100 ich
zeige euch jetzt einfach mal wie die von
innen aussehen und macht es jetzt hier
auf essen könnt ihr übrigens auch im
löffel also de könnt da jetzt im löffel
reingehen und es raus löffeln oder ihr
macht eben das förmchen direkt auf und
dann kann man das hier einfach stehlen
ist natürlich schade wenn man dann das
förmchen kaputt macht aber man kann das
sowieso nur einmal benutzt das mache ich
jetzt einfach um euch das zu zeigen
schöner finde ich es wenn man es im
löffel rausnimmt und so sieht es jetzt
aus ich finde es auch ohne förmchen
richtig schön und da teig ich wirklich
richtig richtig schön saftig und die
sind natürlich extrem lecker
und zucchini ist ab sofort wirklich mein
favorit kameramann darf natürlich auch
nicht fehlen
das rezept kameramann bitte nicht so arg
nußbaum das rezept könnt ihr nachlesen
auf www.first orten welt.de die ganzen
produkte und das werkzeug das verlinkt
ich euch natürlich in meiner infobox
hier unten wo information seco steht und
stark legt ihr drauf und kommt dann
direkt auf die verschiedenen produkte
und zum abschluss möchte ich noch eine
vorankündigung machen
die meisten müssen sehr schon durch
instagram oder facebook ich werde
nächste woche am mittwoch als am 16
zwischen 14 und 18 uhr beim globus in
wiesental sein und wetter für euch
backen und würde mich natürlich freuen
wenn mich ganz viele von euch besuchen
kommen hier service ganztägige hände
ich habe ich auch den flyer gemacht da
werde ich auch was backen da gibt es
kostproben
ich werde zeigen wie ich torten
dekoriere es gibt aber auch viele
verschiedene torten zum anschauen und da
freue ich mich ganz arg wenn ihr vorbei
schaut das fernsehen kommt auch baden tv
und eine bitte nur noch es hat mich
schon viele angeschrieben vom bodensee
und von konstanz koblenz wie sie am
besten hierher kommen und mit der
zugverbindung also echt wegen mir müsste
ich nicht kommen von so weit weg dass
ich bisschen unangenehm ihr müsst euch
auch keinen vertrag frei nehmen also
wenn es nicht passt passt nicht
natürlich freue ich mich wenn ihr kommt
aber macht euch keine umstände deswegen
also das ist mir schon fast unangenehm
und ja da freue ich mich schon drauf das
ist jetzt das erste mal und ich freue
mich auf den globus also wie gesagt von
14 bis 18 uhr kommenden mittwoch am 16
im obergeschoss übrigens das wiesental
bei waghäusel und die fresse schreibt
euch einfach auch unten rein und ich
werde morgen nochmal ein oster video
posten weil es jetzt einfach ja ziemlich
schnell geht bis ostern und ich werde
euch jetzt im anschluss noch zwei drei
videos verlinken vom letzten jahr wo ihr
so kleine osterhäschen und ostereier
machen könnt und dann freue ich mich
schon aufs nächste mal wieder und
wünsche euch eine ganz schöne zeit bis
dahin jimmy thimm so hoch zum schluss im
müll
wer den cup technik muss auf den müll
nehmen
david gut da